No matter the movie, Chris Evans always seems
to be having a good time — something made
clear by the outtakes, behind-the-scenes footage,
and bloopers he's left behind.
Here are some times when Evans just couldn't
keep it together while shooting a scene.
Edgar Wright's Scott Pilgrim vs. the World
is a triumph of comedy and sci-fi, and the
whole thing feels like a video game without
coming across as campy.
To be with his dream girl, Ramona Flowers,
Scott must defeat her seven evil exes, including
Lucas Lee, a former skateboarder turned gravelly-voiced
macho movie actor.
Wright enlisted actual action star Chris Evans
to play this fictional action star, although
Evans is probably not as aggressive, frightening,
and toxic as Lucas.
Take for example this moment on set, when
Evans is supposed to be threatening Scott
and instilling deep fear in the underdog.
That's kind of hard to do when you keep losing
your train of thought and forgetting your
dialogue.
“You are a pretty good actor."
"I'm more than pretty good.
That's not the line!”
“I’m not that good.”
Long before Chris Evans and Scarlett Johansson
joined the Avengers, they'd already worked
together twice: In the 2004 college heist
film The Perfect Score, and the 2007 adaptation
of the bestselling novel The Nanny Diaries.
The future Captain America played Hayden,
an upper-crust, Upper East Side "Harvard hottie"
love interest for Johansson's nanny.
The character might be cool and calm, but
Evans certainly isn't.
He has a tough time with wordy mouthfuls of
dialogue.
"And as soon as you get any closer to that
building, you won't be (gibberish)."
He wound up blaming his troubles on loud noises
outside of the camera's view, as well as the
fact that there were half a dozen people running
straight at him.
Solid excuses.
Two most powerful objects in comic book lore
have to be Mjolnir, Thor's mighty hammer,
and Captain America's nigh-invulnerable shield.
As seen throughout hundreds of comic books
and almost as many Marvel Cinematic Universe
movies, Cap's shield gives Mjolnir a run for
its money.
Its unique steel and Vibranium composition
allows it to absorb impact and energy alike.
If Captain America ducks behind it, under
it, or over it, he can keep himself safe from
pretty much anything in the universe.
This blooper captured on the set of Captain
America: The Winter Soldier shockingly revealed
the only thing so powerful that not even this
impeccable weapon and piece of protective
gear can make it bend to its will: a door.
That shield is just a prop, and it doesn't
give Evans the oomph he needs to bust down
the big door.
Chris Evans just can't seem to get a break,
props-wise.
Did he accidentally offend someone in the
Marvel Studios prop department?
Did he skip "acting with props day" in drama
school?
For whatever reason, there are even more bloopers
involving props not cooperating with the guy
who just wants to play Captain America with
proper gravitas.
To his credit, Evans gives it his all.
“We need a plan of attack.”
This backpack is the greatest villain Captain
America has ever faced or will ever face onscreen,
it seems.
It wriggles its way out of Evans' control
over and over again.
In Spider-Man: Homecoming, Evans' Captain
America makes a cameo appearance, starring
in a short educational film that Peter Parker
watches in school.
It's an arrangement that makes sense — if
any Avenger is going to film a public service
announcement to remind all the boys and girls
out there to eat a nutritious, balanced lunch,
it's Captain America.
He's a product of the 1940s, when such aw-shucks,
gee-whiz kinds of PSAs from movie serial and
radio stars were the norm.
Of course, this is all so ridiculous that
not even Evans can get through it with a straight
face.
“Hi, I'm Captain America.
Whether you're a student, or a soldier, there's
one thing that will always give you an edge:
A hot lunch."
It's a super-dramatic, pivotal moment in Avengers:
Age of Ultron.
In a commanding, "everybody pay attention"
tone, and with cohort Black Widow at his side,
a suited-up, ready for battle Captain America
boldly intones, "Avengers…" but then stops.
It's like he's waiting for a dramatic musical
stinger.
The audience is waiting for an "Assemble"
to finish the catch phrase.
But it never comes.
"Avengers…
Ehhhh?"
It would seem Evans was pausing for effect
before delivering the classic line.
He was probably just messing around for fun,
because he quickly turns the moment into a
goof.
And the movie itself cuts to the credits before
the line finishes.
Acting isn't the most physically taxing or
mentally draining job in the world, but it's
not without its challenges, particularly when
the job is acting in a superhero movie.
Playing Captain America involves a lot of
physicality for Evans.
He's had to do one-on-one fight scenes and
tightly choreographed group fight scenes,
pretended to operate vehicles, dangled from
wires, and taken on villains in front of a
green screen.
He also has to run a lot.
Captain America is always running to dole
out good old fashioned American justice to
bad guys.
In this take for a pulse-pounding scene for
Captain America: The Winter Soldier, Cap and
Falcon quickly hoof it up to where they need
to be, but in the wrong direction.
“How do we know the good guys from the bad
guys?
We're supposed to be running…"
This Avengers moment is all about sheer chaos:
A climactic, apocalyptic battle rages, resulting
in death and destruction.
These moments are among the toughest for a
film crew to commit to celluloid, as there
are so many moving parts involved in getting
it just right.
That also means the chance for something to
go wrong is much higher than it is for a simple,
straightforward scene.
In this instance, one Chris or the other is
the thing that goes wrong.
His Captain America lays on the ground, a
leg awkwardly hanging in the air above him,
awaiting a cue from co-star Chris Hemsworth.
"Oh, is Thor comin' in?"
But since Evans is the one laying there in
the foreground of the shot, he's the one who
has to take one for the team.
And he does it with a laugh.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.